to recognize that so much of modernity
has been amazing for humanity and has
given us the level of comfort and
productivity and connection that we have
and
that is we do not forget that when we
also point out that the amazing rate of
change that we ourselves have created is
itself deranging us and making it very
difficult to understand how to be human
and how to remember how to be human
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased today to have
some friends of mine on heather heing
and brett weinstein they're evolutionary
biologists who've been invited to
address the us congress the department
of justice and the department of
education
and they've spoken to audiences across
the globe they both earned phds in
biology from the university of michigan
where their research on evolution and
adaptation earned awards for its quality
and innovation they have been visiting
fellows at princeton university and
before that were professors at the
evergreen state college for 15 years
they resigned from evergreen in the wake
of the 2017 campus riots that focused in
part on their opposition to a day of
racial segregation and another college
equity proposal
they co-host weekly live streams of the
dark horse podcast and are both quite
well known to many people in my audience
it's a pleasure to have you guys here
today i just read your new book
i'm very much looking forward to talking
about it i you have a copy maybe we
could see it
it is a pleasure to be with you jordan
thank you yes thank you great to see you
again jordan and great to be back on
your podcast thank you a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century
so let's talk about that i've got some
questions uh well first of all maybe we
should maybe we should ask why why did
you write it what was your purpose
well uh in the many years that we were
teaching at evergreen we were deploying
what we called the evolutionary toolkit
which was a set of concepts that allowed
people to understand
the nature of biological creatures and
the nature of they themselves and many
of our students asked us if there was
not some way
some
form in which we could provide them the
toolkit so that they could hand it off
to people who weren't in our classes and
events have conspired so as to allow us
to to write that book and we've now done
it we're very excited to finally have
the toolkit in the world
so there was a broad question that was
popping around in my mind while i was
reading this
i mean you you do state in the book that
it's very difficult to derive shoulds so
pathways for behavior from scientific
facts and scientific data but in some
sense the book is an attempt to
uh what would you say extract out from
biological knowledge certain guidelines
for behavior guidelines for thinking and
so it looks like it's in part an attempt
to bridge the ought the is ought gap to
speak philosophically and did you did
you think about that explicitly when you
were writing the book
well it is you know we we do we point
out that the naturalistic fallacy is
something to be avoided exactly as you
just alluded to you know we what we know
to be true does not necessarily mean
that that's what ought to be true or
what we ought to aspire to but i think
what we what we do consistently in the
book and in our teaching and in our
lives
is
try to understand what we've been
who we are and not just you know what we
are evolutionarily from an anatomical
and physiological perspective but from a
behavioral perspective and a cultural
perspective
and thus make the most meaning that we
can
from what we've been to what we can be
yeah well you talk about human
universals for example and and
you speak about them biologically
sets of emotions we have language the
use of shelter the fact that we all live
in groups that we imitate that status is
part of our
what would you say psychological concern
existential concern the division of
labor artistic production and and so
and so you know you could you could
think in some sense that if that's what
human beings have always done that
there's some and and that's what we are
in some sense that there's some utility
and having some respect for that and
that seems to be at least a tentative
bridge between the is ought
chasm
um for what it's worth i don't think
there's really any conflict between what
we've tried to do here and the obvious
difficulty of extracting extracting an
offerman is
the fact is
we have values ultimately they may not
be defensible from a scientific
perspective in fact if you take it to an
extreme it's difficult to
establish a reason that existing is
better than not existing in some sense
that's a subjective
preference and it's one that it's not
surprising we all share because we are
the descendants of many creatures who
have preferred it
but in an absolute sense it may not be
defensible so what we do in the book is
we inform the question of what ought to
be
with a scientific understanding and we
believe that any credible ought needs to
be informed in this way at least in
modern times and where we arrive
is at the conclusion that we cannot in
fact go back there is no place for us to
return to that would be sensible from
the point of view of modern people and
we cannot go forward in a chaotic way we
have to recognize that there are many
things about what we were that need to
be preserved and updated there are other
things that need to be jettisoned and
that it is that renegotiation of our
relationship with each other and with
the planet that is the um the focus of
where we must go
and you talk at the beginning about
uh
the new landscape that sits in front of
us and
you also discuss that in relationship to
the human niche and so one of the issues
you confront very early in the book is
this notion of hyper novelty and i mean
i i i've been very ill for a long time
and so i've sort of woken back up and i
have all this new electronic stuff
around me that i don't know how to use
and it's it can do so much
and
it but it's very very hard to
figure out how to make it work and i
know perfectly well that that problem is
not going away like it's going to be
twice as bad in a year and twice as bad
again a year after that and so
what
what's this idea of hyper novelty in
more detail
well at one level and i'll let brett
finish continuing on after i answer but
at one level the book is an invitation
to consider trade-offs in all things
to recognize that so much of modernity
has been amazing for humanity and has
given us the level of comfort and
productivity
and connection that we have and
that is we do not forget that when we
also point out that the amazing rate of
change that we ourselves have created is
itself deranging us and making it very
difficult to understand how to be human
and how to remember how to be human
so i would add that
the
the fact of novel technology of course
exists in obvious forms in the types of
devices that you're referring to but it
also
uh
fits well with many other things novel
molecules that we encounter novel ways
of socially interacting and the problem
is that although we are the most
flexible creature that selection has
ever produced
our level of flexibility is not up to a
rate of change where we literally do not
mature into the same world in which we
were born by the time we become adults
we live in some different context and
what this means
at an intuitive level is that we do not
know what to do our intuitions are badly
tuned for the kinds of things that we
encounter and this is made particularly
bad in the context of markets where
our our intuitions can be hijacked to
get us to engage in behavior that
benefits the people producing
the content but at some cost to us
so we have to become aware of this
hazard and we have to
learn to apply the breaks to it it's not
that progress is bad progress is often
tremendous
but it almost always comes with
important unintended consequences and
being aware of them is uh an important
feature right right so so that's a
permanent part in some sense of the
proper political debate right and so you
think we face a horizon of of genuinely
and truly unpredictable change no one
knows what's going to happen in the next
10 years at all
and so the cons the liberal types who
think more
would you say loosely and in with more
associations more creatively
they're going to produce solutions
hypothetically to those unpredictable
problems but the conservative types are
always saying yeah but be careful guys
because your damn solutions might be
worse than the problem and so and you
can never say that one side of that
argument has the floor properly you
never know because it really is
unpredictable and so if that debate
between the liberals and the
conservatives isn't allowed to exist in
an untrembled manner we actually
interfere with our fundamental
problem-solving uh what would you
problem-solving ability both
individually and collectively and when
you talked about our our niche
being niche switching you know that we
and that's i mean part of the reason
that i thought that the hero's story in
some sense is at the top of the value
hierarchy is because the hero story is
about
niche switching
it's about the transformation of
viewpoints and so well what should all
viewpoints be subject to the
transformation of viewpoints when
necessary it's something like that and i
thought that dovetailed with this idea
of niche switching being one of human
beings prime so maybe you could explain
that niche switching idea and the niche
idea too because lots of people don't
know what that is
yeah well so in in ecology the idea of a
niche is that part of the environment to
which an organism is best adapted
and most organisms have a relatively
narrow set of environmental conditions
which includes both the plants around
them the soil the you know the the
climate and the weather all of these
things the geology
to which they are best able to exist and
as they extend towards the borders of
that uh of that niche they do less and
less well and there's some area outside
of it that they don't do well and humans
of course as is widely understood have
managed to excel in on every continent
of the planet that has plants right you
know we we have explored everything
successfully and so we argue in the book
that while um it is well understood in
ecology and evolution that every
organism has a niche the human niche is
in fact niche switching that is what we
do that we are able to move from
you know hunting marine mammals on the
coast
inland to hunting salmon inland further
to hunting large large
terrestrial mammals and that's just an
example from a pre-industrial
pre-agricultural moment right we can
imagine any number of transformations
that humans have have been involved with
and this implies that we have a
mechanism for
swapping out our programming which we we
clearly do if you think about what
happens as a population moves through
time and changes what it does for a
living there's a mechanism for getting
there it's not a haphazard process
and we argue that this process will have
unfolded very frequently around
campfires as individuals come to
consciousness of a collective kind what
they do is they pool their cognitive
resources they do a kind of parallel
processing asymmetric parallel
processing where they share ideas and
individuals with very different
strengths and blind spots engage the
same question
and the whole is greater than the sum of
the parts that process allows human
beings
to literally bootstrap a new software
program for their population and that is
the key to human success okay so when i
was reading jung's
thoughts so his conception of the self
was an underlying mechanism that allowed
ego
frames to be transformed so imagine at
any point it's like this niche idea at
any point you're identified with your
adaptation to a certain niche
but now and then the niche transforms
and so you have to transform or die
and so but you're identified as you with
that adaptation and so that's
experienced in some sense as an ego
death and then the the question is well
when that ego death occurs what does it
collapse into and jung's idea was
there's an underlying structure that he
called the self that is there stably
across across transformations of
proximate identity he also associated
that at least in part with the voice of
conscience which was a voice that was
telling you that your current adaptation
despite your identification with it
wasn't optimized
it wasn't optimized i suppose that's the
right way of thinking about it so
yeah and many moderns especially those
of us who are spending so much of our
time on screens and in social media now
too often conflate those two things
right conflate the ego identity with the
self if i'm remembering your use of
jung's terms correctly um and you know
this this is exactly the problem and
that is exactly the problem right that's
a really interesting
you wrote an essay called relations
between the ego and the unconscious
which is one of the most brilliant
things he ever wrote that is exactly
discussing that problem and it's
catastrophic danger it's brilliant but
it's very hard to figure out what it's
about if you don't have this initial
conception yeah and so not only so it's
exactly the problem for individuals and
also for one individual assessing
another and so you know the way that we
would we used to frame it in our
classrooms without the jungian framing
was we're not going to conflate
uh a person's idea that you may find
objectionable with a dislike of the
person themselves
the person's ideas is skating on top are
skating on top of what their actual
self is but it's it's very easy to fall
prey to that conflation
so uh
the
parallel you point out is actually
reflective of an overarching similarity
an analogy between developmental
progress and evolutionary process and so
what jung is focused on there is a
developmental analog of what we talk
about with respect to lineages
transforming what they do an individual
coming to do something different than
they did before is involved in a process
that looks very much like that and will
have many of the same features as they
well
okay so while you could think about that
too is you know the prefrontal cortex
grew out of the motor cortex and so what
that means is the prefrontal cortex has
basically evolved to abstract out
patterns of action
in abstraction so that they can be
assessed and killed dispensed with with
before being instantiated in behavior
and so that is
that is in fact a replication of the
evolutionary process in abstraction so
that we can have our ideas die instead
of us and we do that in the political
landscape if we're smart right because
part of the debate is well here's a
bunch of good ideas we should act them
out it's like wait a minute
some of those might kill you and you do
a lot of that kind of warning in this
book right because you talk about the
necessity of creative adaptation but the
book is full of cautions about
unintended consequences and so
for example you talk about and i hate
this all these gadgets we have around us
it's engineers hey they're all autistic
and obsessed with blinking light so
every damn thing you have has to have a
light on it and i finally bought a
router where you could shut off the
lights it's like more power to them but
it's not trivial you point out for
example that we're not well adapted to
sleep if there's any blue light around
and so we have these gadgets we're very
sensitive to even dim light and so we
have these gadgets around that are
polluting the darkness and well that's
not nothing and that's a good really
good example of an unintended
consequence
yeah it's really it's it's not nothing
at all and i think you know we see we
have been lucky enough to live in a
space for many decades now where we
could make a totally dark and mostly
silent
nightscape for ourselves but whenever we
travel
the the presence of at least one blue
led blinking somewhere in the room in
which you're supposed to sleep is almost
ubiquitous in pretty much every other
room that we have been exposed to
and that suggests that uh right there we
have a likely explanation for at least
part of the derangement of moderns right
there sleep disruption we know we need
sleep you know we argue in the book
we're aliens to land here with the
technology to have gotten here they
would not be confused by the fact that
we spent a third of our lives in
apparent dormancy because they too would
sleep sleep is sleep is necessary now
well one of the first things you do as a
clinician to treat people with
depression is to try to regulate their
sleeping because it's such a basic
biorhythm that if it's fouled up then
your entire your
your emotional regulation deteriorates
tremendously and so these small
hypothetically small changes and of
course light at night is not a small
change night is dark
and and we didn't have light except fire
and you point out in the book that you
know and this is rangham's work a lot of
it which you cite you know that we've
probably been messing about with fire
for something approximating two million
years and so nighttime fire that's a
whole different thing that's the right
kind of light but and well you know one
of the things that's interesting about
your book and the way you think is that
you're using biology in some sense also
to point out
what we should be
wary of because it's going to disrupt us
our biological function in ways that
that might not be so good for us and so
it's health advice in some sense even
though a lot of it seems to be
behavioral so
well it's health advice in the sense
that we are unhealthy because of all of
this hyper novelty at virtually every
scale and so when you say that
light in the middle of the night is not
a small matter
we point to the possibility in the book
that in some sense
wavelengths of light that tend towards
day that include a lot of blue misinform
us about when we are active and for many
of us we may be able to tolerate that if
we can get past the simple sleep
disruption but for some of us it may be
activating the dream state while awake
and that the degree to which simply
would mirror the kinds of symptoms that
come along with schizophrenia is
conspicuously simply rightly activating
the dream states simply activating the
dream state also there's a question
about
given that we have
these cycles of sleep and that we wake
very differently under natural
circumstances than we do under modern
circumstances
it is uh an open question as to how much
cost there is to awaking arbitrarily as
a result of your alarm suddenly
triggering your ability to interrupt
these cycles immediately if there's an
emergency right that can't possibly be
good for you and we are built not to do
it and so the idea that oh i'll just put
an alarm clock by my bed and i'll get up
at 6 30
at what cost and i think we simply don't
know
no that's that's so interesting that so
many of those technological innovations
well this is the conservative speaking
again it's like you think you know what
that thing is but don't be thinking you
do that the existentialists called that
alienation taking a page to some degree
from the marxists and
par but in a much broader conception
which was well you're alienated from
your creation in some sense because
it has a life of its own because it it
contains way more possibility than you
thought you packed into it and that damn
possibility is going to unfold across
time in ways that you can't possibly
predict and so that's wonderful because
everything is so deep and mysterious
because of that but it's also it's like
that's a genie and you can't put the
genie back in the bottle and you don't
even know where the damn things are it's
amazing we've actually managed to
survive all this technological
revolution you know and
it's it's really something that we've
been able to adapt to it so far
god only knows what twitter is doing to
us for example you know
it points to the hubris that we have
right the arrogance
of of all of us not just creating but
accepting all of the hyper novelty into
our world as if we already have a
complete understanding of what humans
are and what we need and you know we
point as you know in the book to many
passing examples that now look laughable
you know to doctors at in the early
1900s deciding that not only was the
appendix unnecessary but so was the
large intestine let's just cut those out
of people right this is going to be a
lot more space in there a lot of space
yeah we probably need more space and our
that's right what could it possibly be
doing no so this is easy right it's easy
with hindsight of 100 years but we have
to ask are we so certain that we've
attained god-like knowledge now that
we're not making any of these mistakes
well it's also god-like ethics and you
know
the fact that we're so damn powerful
means we better be better because the
lookout you know and this we just have
no idea what's coming i was talking to a
good friend of mine who's a brilliant
computer engineer and he's working on
this damn thing that he thinks is more
revolutionary than the internet and he
isn't someone who just says that and
he's already done this like five times
it's like and i thought oh my god do we
really need something more revolutionary
and then i thought he is a wise person
and he's careful thank god
and you know don't no doubt there's 10
things coming that are more
revolutionary than the internet you know
i heard about like about three of them
this week and it's really something and
i hope we're bloody well up to it and
you know one of the things i hate to
like ramble on about jung but one of the
things he did say back in the 1950s
which really this was in relationship to
thermonuclear weapons he said
the most serious crisis facing us in the
future will be mass
psychosis essentially mass delusions
it'll be psychological instability
because we can't ex we can't afford that
and be this powerful
so
you were talking about your friend and
his idea and you said something akin to
i hope he's up to it he's at least
you know capable of seeing the hazards
but the problem is there's no level of
wise that covers this none no for you
know you mentioned twitter
it's early with twitter we don't really
know its full effects but i think we can
be pretty sure it's not making us nicer
or better informed even if that seemed
like it might be a consequence but if
you imagine
i mean i remember you know it wasn't so
long ago that twitter was a novel idea
and
can you imagine saying well what will be
the effect if suddenly everybody can
you know say 140 characters at a time
anything they want at everybody the idea
is well
what's the harm in that yeah right well
so we could talk about that a bit i mean
because we don't know much about our
linguistic function we have no idea what
the combination of 140 character limit
no
censorship or social scrutiny at the
moment
does to the emotions we're likely to
manifest when we communicate in that
manner we have zero idea and by the time
we figure it out twitter will be
something else so it won't matter right
and add to that add to that the um the
fact that we're not engaging with whole
human beings
right that that it's entirely behind a
facade
some of those facades are real people
you know i know when i see a tweet from
you that it's actually you who is behind
that um there are other people who might
know entirely online and i think i think
they are who they say they are there's
other accounts that are actually
anonymous and they're consistent and i
think they're going to be consistent but
who really knows and of course there are
far more that may not be people at all
right right i mean that'll be a bigger
and bigger problem right we either be
hired and are actually real people or
they're just not even people so yeah
i think 60 percent of the internet
traffic is bought something like yeah so
yeah so pretty much it's going to be
just
yeah we're learning to conflate
real people with fake people yeah well
you have no way to tell the difference
think about this too you know so you're
driving around in your car and it's a
shell it sort of looks like a beetle
because the engineers hide the
complexity from you because that's what
you want and then you see these other
people in their in their shell beetle
shells and you curse and swear at them
like you never would if they were right
in front of you and that means that just
putting that facade on them dehumanizes
them to the point where you're much more
aggressive than you would otherwise be
and so we have no idea how that works
out in the social sphere even even
conversing like this which seems like
the real thing you know and maybe is
close enough
that we don't know what that does to the
to the likely emotional tone of her
interactions no that's that's right it's
it's arbitrary is the answer and i i
agree with you exactly your your example
of cars is a great one but one thing
that we can be pretty sure
is that if people treated each other uh
in person the way they treat each other
on twitter
they would get beaten up with some
regularity which would stop them from
doing right and so the net effect might
be that you know we would be nicer right
and so the uh the suspension of the
actual violence may cause us to become
uh much more dangerous as we're trying
to problem solve and navigate well yeah
and then we could talk about that for a
minute too because you might think well
violence is no solution it's like no but
one of the things that you do see in
interactions between men is that there
is an underlying threat of physical
violence that's always there and you
think well that's a terrible thing those
those demonic males that's rangham's
book right but but by the same token
you can signal
a tiny increase in the potential for
that violence in a variety of ways by
frowning by changing your voice tone so
you just have to hint at it if it's a
civilized discussion and it keeps it
within bounds and that's one of the
things that i don't see so
characteristic of
linguistic interactions between women
for example yeah so it's it's not and i
would just add um to pick up on a point
that you made earlier
you know you said the prefrontal cortex
inspiring from the motor cortex uh well
it's also specifically in mammals the
cerebral cortex is borrowing from
uh what used to do our smell processing
and you know so as as primates we're
much more visual uh than the rest of
mammals which are much more focused on
smell with it with this increase in the
size of the telencephalon but what you
know what all are we missing when we're
doing something that feels very much in
person like what what you and we are
doing right now but we're not smelling
each other and you know that's your
sexual interactions that's got to be
crucial man right and it's mostly not
conscious like humans yeah we supposedly
don't have pheromones well let's see
yeah right
right
yeah right but we know that we're in
person with one another there's little
things about body language about
movements about little gestures and
facial movements that don't convey even
over screens and certainly don't convey
otherwise when i was in college i lived
with like six narrative wells and and a
couple of pretty decent women and one of
the women had this she had her moods you
know and i swore that i could tell if
she was in a frozen mood when i walked
into the house
i thought i know something's up here and
i and that happened like six or seven
times maybe it's you know superstition
or whatever but i really think it had
something to do with smell
and i also had this very strange
experience when there was someone in my
house that was pretty much homicidal and
ready to go off that night in a very not
good way a very person who was very
disturbed a good friend of mine who
eventually committed suicide and
i woke up at like three in the morning
and i thought no something's seriously
wrong and i went into his room and he
was sitting there up on his bed and i
knew what he was thinking and i swear
and my my my brother was sleeping he was
visiting me from from western canada a
couple thousand miles away he was in the
other room completely different room he
told me the next day independent of this
interaction i had with my friend who was
staying with us
that
he said what the hell was going on last
night i couldn't sleep at all
and i really think it was smell
associated
who knows
it could be but it also you know one of
the things about human beings is that we
have really no idea what most of our
minds are up to and so you don't know
what you're tracking you could be
tracking that when somebody is in a mood
that they walk across the floor in a
particular way where that board doesn't
squeak or it does squeak or something
about their pattern of behavior has just
been recorded as a precursor to
something bad and so it might as well be
smell or that might be a metaphor i can
just smell something's coming um
well just think about dogs try taking
your dog to the vet without him knowing
it's like what the hell is that dog
figuring out it's non-verbal clearly
it's like you think your dog can't
understand language and get some of it
but man
dogs they know and that's probably
because you're not your non-verbal
behavior isn't exactly the same as it
usually is and they're extremely attuned
to that partly because they're not
actually
blinded by their linguistic ability
right because our linguistic ability
actually inhibits some of that
non-verbal decoding at least our
conscious awareness of it yeah we make
the mistake of thinking if we're using
language we're being purely analytical
and we forget all of the things that
underlie the analytical
yeah like all the musical tone
yeah in fact uh
this is uh this is my hypothesis for why
we have these greetings that carry
zero content in them is that it's very
hard to hide from somebody who knows you
that you know there's something on your
mind if you say i'm fine right but you
just don't get the tone color exactly
right they're confined
exactly
um right but but there's an awful lot
that's communicated and well you see
that with small talk too you know and
i've talked to a lot of
hyper-intellectual people and i was kind
of like this at one time it's like small
talk you know who's got time for that
it's like no you probably don't want to
be around anyone who doesn't have time
for small talk and because small talk is
well first of all it isn't
um energy requiring and that's really
actually really quite nice and it's also
an indication that the person
has some social skills you know they
know how to just have an introductory
conversation and not jump right into
what's dead serious and all those things
we do to smooth the waters that well
that a technology like twitter just
eliminates and we also don't know how
twitter samples people like twitter may
only allow people who are irritated
about something to talk
that's right that's right and to your
point about small talk i i too
have dismissed small talk in the past as
something you know not not worth my time
and i think i've come around as you have
it sounds like uh to the idea that it's
actually much like you maybe could smell
or you heard the floorboards or
something with your friend who was in an
apparently homicidal mood that night uh
small talk allows you to take the
temperature metaphorically literally
maybe of of the mood of the interaction
and get a sense for okay how am i as we
go deeper how should i play this like
you know do i do i go in guns blazing do
i take a little easy you know what what
kinds of things is the person that i'm
interacting with likely to be able to
engage able and willing to engage right
now well it's probably a form of play so
when kids get together on the say two
kids of
roughly the same age get together on the
playground and decide if they're going
to play they start with little and play
that's below their developmental level
and then they both ratchet it up to
their own developmental level and if
they're if they match then their good
play partners but they start you know
with something that's actually quite
quite beneath them and then they also
tend to evaluate you know if they're
dealing with someone who is
developmentally much
delayed in comparison to them they'll
tend to find another play partner and of
course we do that as adults that's right
as we as we make our progress through
the social interactions
so
okay so
so let's also talk about
objections to evolutionary theory you
know you biological essentialist types
you know
so
how do you respond to those sorts and
there is a danger right look there's a
real danger that we should that we
should address here
we here follow the science a lot and we
hear these un thinking claims that well
the science will just tell us what to do
without any any intermediation of such
pesky things as politics or
and so
and so when people are criticizing
evolutionary theory as psychology they
are
to give the devil is due they're also
going after what might be a two-facile
tendency to say well this is and since
it is i can make it should and it's
science that's me allowing me to do that
and that's that's not good that's not
good for science or everyone else so
how how do you
handle that philosophical problem let's
say when you're trying to write a book
like this
um
two points which are really probably
facets of the same point
one we are very early in the study of
biology unlike things like physics and
chemistry and we are also in a different
kind of scientific realm complex fields
function very differently than simple
fields and unfortunately our model of
how science works is built on the places
where we succeeded early and we're going
to have to revise the way we do science
for for biology and psychology and all
of the related
disciplines
and i would say a couple things one
i think there's a perception in certain
camps very frequently they are
non-academic camps in which there's a
recognition that there's something
missing from evolutionary theory
and what i would say is we agree there's
something missing from evolutionary
theory what we tend to disagree about is
what is there and from our perspective
there is a missing
layer of darwinism in other words the
darwinian story we tell about how a
creature like a human being arises
through this process is an incomplete
story and many people detect that
incompleteness the question though is is
that an indicator
of some
divine force of force outside of physics
something like that or is it an
indicator that there is a darwinian
process that has yet to be described
okay so i really want to ask you guys
about your opinion about this because
that that's a real crucial issue as far
as i'm concerned so
as far as i know
darwin outlined both natural selection
and sexual selection and he put a fair
emphasis on sexual selection
but
when biologists
started to unpack darwin's ideas for
about seven decades eight decades after
he wrote his great books most of the
emphasis was on this like blind natural
selection
and the thing that's so interesting
about sexual selection and i think this
is true as organisms become more complex
is that it implies in a very non-trivial
manner that consciousness is directing
selection through mate choice
and so you know this idea that we have
that spirit
compels matter to emerge towards
complexity has something going for it
that i it that seems to me to be
deeply rooted in darwinian theories of
sexual selection it's like and you see
this emerging in very weird ways so i'll
give you one example that you may know
of i don't know if you've seen that
youtube video i think it's from a bbc
nature documentary of that damn puffer
fish making a mandela sculpture at the
bottom of the ocean it's like it's like
20 feet across this thing it's about
eight inches deep this puffer fish is
like this big he spends four days making
this incredible sculpture and this is a
bloody puffer fish and and then the
females come and take a look at his
sculpture and think you know he's kind
of a creative artsy type of puffer fish
and he's pretty practical from an
engineering perspective and so you know
he might make a good mate and that's a
puffer fish you know so
well and then in the bauer birds which
are also extremely interesting examples
of that obviously they are being
selected by the females in particular
for high levels of creative intelligence
and practical engineering skill and so
there is a role of conscious choice so
because you keep hearing about the blind
forces of natural selection it's yeah
fair enough but
what about sexual selection
and then what does that say about what
consciousness is doing and i i don't
think i can't
because that's not mechanistic in some
way i
well that's all i have to say about that
i don't know where you think about all
that you're exactly right your
your sacrilege is dead on
um
and you know you can detect that this is
the error with the following
version of the same puzzle right we
swear
that
evolution does not look forward
right on the other hand we also swear
that we are the products of evolution
and we certainly look forward right we
can project forward in time so
if it is true that selection can build a
creature that can model the future then
is it true that evolution cannot model
the future that seems wrong right so
anyway we could parse the details of
that but the basic thing is look we are
not dealing with darwinism 1.0 we're
dealing with darwinism 10.0 or something
like that where
the original crude haphazard process has
built refinements that allow it to
function much more effectively than it
otherwise would which is exactly why we
say there's a missing layer and
as a placeholder for that the the
terminology which i've used which has
gotten me in a ton of hot water is
explorer mode right the idea is how does
evolution 10.0 explore design space in
something other than a haphazard fashion
because of course a lineage that
explores in a haphazard fashion is a
terrible disadvantage i got to say
something i got to say something about
that so i had this vision of play
okay so
and
i first saw that the fundamental role of
the patriarchal spirit in a household
was something like the provision of a
safe place for play
and then i could see children as
experimenting with different
manifestations of their physical being
that's in play and that's relevant
epigenetically as far as i'm concerned
because what they're doing is modeling
potential ways of being in their play
and then they instantiate those
physically and i don't know how deep
into the biology that goes but it's but
it's not trivial this because they are
playing with alternate forms of being in
play and of course we are neotenous you
adult human beings and we play a lot
and so
we've retained that ability into
adulthood
so so take take what you just said about
play and epigenetics and extrapolate it
to birth order effects
right birth order effects which are
either a failure of selection because if
there's some best way to be then where
you are in the birth order shouldn't
affect it
but there's another way of interpreting
it a much better way of interpreting it
that says depending upon what has come
before you what you should be will have
been changed and there may be
predictable patterns in the way it will
have been changed and so your point
about a child
exploring your child is effectively
exploring developmental niche space
which is altered by the siblings that
came before
yes okay and so and so now you have
built into your genetics this is maybe a
discussion of something like human
potential so you know when you go into a
new environment
new
proteins are coded for by genetic
structure so partly you think up new
ideas in a new place but that isn't all
that happens is that when you go into a
new place there is new biochemical
potential that's being unlocked within
you and that's part of the reason why
going many places makes you you know
more than you were and so that's deeply
coded all the way down to the molecular
level by the looks of things that's
right and that's um to your earlier
question about doesn't an evolutionary
interpretation of what we are faked us
to
to a preordained conclusion well no it
doesn't and part of the answer to why is
this concept of reaction norms where you
can start from a very similar starting
point you and someone else and end up in
a very different place because of the
environment to which you were exposed
and so some of the examples from
non-human space of this would be
tadpoles of some species that if they
are raised among kin they become sort of
docile vegetarians with small mouths and
if they are raised among non-kin they
become carnivorous uh cannibals who
are going to tell you a story about that
if you don't mind so when my daughter
was very little we went to a pool a
swamp you know on someone's farmland and
she collected about 50 tadpoles and
brought them home put them in an
aquarium
and one tadpole lived and it ate all the
others and then it turned into a frog
which she had for about three years but
i had no idea tadpoles were carnivorous
but apparently if you adjust the niche
properly then there you go so i didn't
know it was only non-kin
it's well it's it's different in
different species but it's a density
dependent response
to the environment density dependent and
kind dependent response to the
environment and this suggests that you
know just to say that we are
evolutionary beings does not fade us to
one particular thing we have to be
paying really close attention to what
our environment is and just one more one
more story that's a bit similar here
with regard to the bauer birds that you
brought up and play in explorer modes is
that in one species of bear birds where
the males build these beautiful bowers
you know much like palaces for the
females to come by and assess the males
know as they build them which direction
the females are going to come through
and in fact they in some cases sort of
build the pathway so the females always
come from a particular direction and
they actually build forced perspective
just like human artists forced
perspective into their bowers such that
from the place that the females will
first view them they look bigger and
grander than they actually are
and you know this again is the way that
males can modify what females will think
of them and enhance okay so let's think
about that really seriously let's and
let's just talk about the birds
so what exactly is it do you think that
the bauer bird male is demonstrating and
what is it exactly that the female is
looking for because you might think well
what the hell does cr like nest building
artistic creativity have to do with a
bower bird but something and and there's
some analogy to well human beauty
because they actually make beautiful
things these birds and they look
beautiful to us which is you know kind
of peculiar all things considered what
what are they selecting for
uh it's a very good question
i'm a little bit
in some sense this is part of the
subject of the next book
but i will maybe
preview that a little bit for you since
you asked such a good question
the
problem so this kind of behavior is very
common amongst
birds
right and birds create a special hazard
the females face a special hazard in
choosing a mate because birds can fly
so let's say that a female is selected
to find a male who's in very good
condition if he's only going to get
gametes from him and therefore genes
then his very good condition might
indicate that he has very good genes
that's standard evolutionary theory but
the problem is what does good genes mean
does it mean some general good genes or
does it mean good genes that will be
good for her offspring where her
offspring will exist and so if a male
has gotten well fed in a remote location
and then flies in and demonstrates that
he is well fed it may indicate nothing
at all or it may even be
counterproductive from the point of view
of her searching for genes that will be
well matched to her own in the
environment in which her chicks will
grow up
so
one thing she may want to assess is
did you get well fed
here
and the thing about bauer birds we could
go on for hours about this but the thing
about these bowers which have no
function whatsoever they are not nests
they don't provide shelter they just
simply are these
structures that demonstrate something
is that males will steal from each other
so a male who is not present will lose
materials and his borrower will degrade
as a result of theft from neighboring
males he will also typically have a
behavior like a dance right in which he
will perfect in the exact location he
will dance around the objects of his
bower and so if a female let's say that
a male does the words i want to see my
etchings
let's say that a male
flies in right or a well-fed male flies
in from somewhere where food is abundant
and then he because he's a big brood
evicts a local male who's built a
beautiful bower all right and then a
female comes and she assesses the bower
looks great then she assesses the dance
won't look great because he hasn't
practiced it there right he just flew in
he's a faker right she'll detect that
okay
um whereas if he's you're a thief and
you're a thief from far away furthermore
right
now let's say that he
flies in and he gets the bower and but
he has to stick around long enough to
learn the to dance around this power
that he didn't build well he's gonna
have to spend a lot of time foraging
away from the power right and so he may
look well but the bower may be degraded
even if his dance looks good also a
no-go
how about a male who's again done the
worst thing and he's evicted the local
resident and he flies in
he evicts the local resident he manages
to feed himself but spend enough time at
the bower that he can defend it and
practice his dance well then even though
he's stolen the power the female is
getting a proper indication that his
genes are well suited to the local
environment he's feeding himself well
here he's been here long enough that
he's learned the dance he's defended his
bower probably a good bet so even in the
case of the bower isn't his construction
it might be a an honest indicator of his
genetic quality
so one of the things when i was reading
evolutionary psychology and and trying
to parcel out uh you know differences in
sexual attraction markers between men
and women i'll tell you a brief story as
an intro to this so when i was an
undergraduate at the university of
alberta
i had you know i had some success with
women but not much
and then i went to mcgill and i was a
graduate student and nothing changed
really in the couple of months between
when i was a
you know senior undergraduate at in
alberta and when i was a low-level
graduate student in
montreal but
how attractive women were to me changed
a lot and i thought well that's not you
that's something about status and i
already knew that evolutionary
theory there and you know that women are
more affected by let's say social status
in relationship to sexual attractiveness
than men are but then i thought that
through to and i thought no no women use
status as a marker for the ability to
gain status in novel environments it's
something like that and so like an
expensive watch or something like that
or a nice suit shows that you have
acquired resources and hints that you
still could even if things fell apart so
it's it's not mere
power or even resources which it's often
parodied at and sometimes as and
sometimes understood as it's a
proximal marker for something much
deeper which is somewhat akin i think to
what you're talking about with regards
to the male bowerbird it's that way
offer no that's that's that's very much
the case and i'll let you continue after
brett but its status is exactly an
honest indicator of the ability to have
and presumably the ability to continue
to
procure resources and frankly this is a
part of the sexual selection literature
of how you know most evolutionary
biologists would would have us
discussing this that is quite unnerving
and rather actually disrespectful
because it imagines
um that female choice that the females
doing the choosing and all of these
species including usually humans are
just being frivolous that they just it
doesn't matter it it's it's simply about
status and what does status matter
anyway whereas exactly what you've done
here is tying it to the reality of how
good a potential medicine is going to be
and the answer to that is going to
depend on whether or not your potential
mate is going to be an active father or
just you know provide gametes and then
disappear you know what quality of mate
what the qualities are that you're
looking for will vary depending on what
kind of creature you are
but the idea that females are just being
frivolous well that we can talk about
status for a minute too and so like if
you look at human social hierarchies and
this is true across the animal kingdom
and then you rank order individuals in
terms of their relative status even in
relatively non-social creatures that
have to occupy the same territory those
that have the best
local niches have offspring that are
much more likely to survive they have
much lower mortality rates and then
there's something else too that that
psychologists have figured out that i
think is right it has a biological
underpinning which is that
your serotonin system
is more effective at modulating your
negative emotion given as a certain
level of stress
the higher you up are are up in a social
hierarchy because you're actually safer
and so that's and so part of what that
implies and this just blew me away when
i sorted it out was that when you go
after
someone's beliefs and they've used their
beliefs to stake a claim to a position
in a hierarchy you're attacking the
structure that's that modulates their
sensitivity to negative emotion
and and you know if you're
hypersensitive to negative emotion you
hyper prepare physiologically so much
that you die way earlier
so this isn't trivial
and it isn't it isn't like the terror
management theorists think that you know
your beliefs somehow regulate your
anxiety directly it's no you have a set
of beliefs that gives you a stake to a
claim in a status hierarchy
and so that's what we do as professors
right we say well look we have this
knowledge and that's why we get this
niche
well then you attack i attack the
validity of your knowledge then i make
you out to be one of those flying bauer
birds that just ripped off the status
hierarchy and
well and then that interferes with your
emotional regulation that's like
well
that's worth thinking about for about 10
years that i think yeah well i think uh
one thing that is true is that our
modern environment and our mismatch our
evolutionary mismatch with it obscures
all of the
elaborate logic that undergirds the
relationship of a normal creature in its
environment or where would have uh
would have characterized our ancestors
in any of the environments from which
they came
and so it's very easy to look for
example
at uh you know modern human females and
see that there's a a preoccupation with
the
level of wealth and status of potential
mates and to read something
uh
superficial
into it but the point is no this is
about deadly serious stuff and it may
not be deadly serious stuff in the
modern environment but the point is the
sensitivity to those things has
everything to do with females in a past
environment uh
sussing out small differences that had
large evolutionary implications for
their lineage going forward
you well i think that your your notion
of niche
transformation niche switching there so
imagine that
partly what the woman is trying to do is
use markers of proximal success as an
indicator of niche switching capacity
now they're in they're in
adequate markers and and that's partly
why they can be criticized you know and
it they're no more accurate than the
claim that just because you're rich
you're good
but it doesn't but status is not exactly
wealth although wealth is a proxy for
status status is more subtle
and but symbols of wealth are pretty
good instantaneous proxies for status
like they're subject to all sorts of
flaws and they're not sufficient but you
know
you have to screen most people out so
you need simple markers to begin with so
heather let me ask you
how do you view as a both as someone
who's female and someone who's an
evolutionary biologist how do you
conceptualize the difference in status
hierarchies in human females and human
males
i'd really be interested to hear that
yeah well this too could go on for 10
years
we are
one of very few species that has
hierarchies and females in hierarchies
and males
other species tend to have one or the
other um there may be a couple maybe
japanese macaques if memories serves
that have both but in those few species
that have both and in all of the species
that have one or the other
the hierarchies are created and
maintained via different different means
and you know there's there's variation
of course but in general uh the
hierarchy in
in males in other species and men in in
humans is
through overt means
through uh fairly direct claims
sometimes it's physical but usually the
physicality is under the surface right
it's you know it's there as a
possibility maybe you want to call it a
threat but usually things don't get
physical as men are deciding
um what what the hierarchy actually is
but there's direct confrontation of a
linguistic sort of a gestural sort of a
oh you're doing that i wouldn't do it
that way or here let me you know we were
often couched in a joke too oh and right
you know and and so maybe that could be
seen as sort of an end run around the
direct provocation but there's there's
very rarely with with men and you know
maybe this is changing in modern times
but if if man a is uh
is
interested in critiquing man b he's very
unlikely to say i'm going to take this
to man and see first i'm going to go
talk to our joint friend and before i
take it directly to to the guy in
um who with whom i have an issue
whereas um so that's you know that tends
to be overt and female hierarchies tend
to be covert in nature and you know this
this probably originates in part through
the fact that even though we seem to be
moving more and more towards a
monogamous
uh mating system and we are therefore
losing our sexual dimorphism in humans
we still are sexually dimorphic and are
still on average smaller and less
muscular and less powerful and so you
know the the ability to back up
disagreement with the threat of
physicality would have been less
successful certainly engaging with men
but also
um with with other women and so we're
more likely women are more likely to use
social signals and covert signals and
less direct signals
to assess and to change what the
hierarchy is there's ton more to say but
maybe i'll leave it at that for the
moment
so let's let's switch you you have a
chapter on sex and gender and that would
be fun to talk about so
first of all i'm really curious about
if you think those terms are importantly
different and if they are why and what
they both mean if they're different so
let's start with that
all right um
they are
different
but
uh the the way in which they relate
actually
uh you can deduce from the omega
principle which we haven't talked about
yet but essentially the
the way of conceptualizing it is uh
heather and i say this slightly
differently but i would say that gender
is the software of sex
and and i tend to say that gender is the
behavioral manifestation of sex
and what this means is that these things
are housed at a different level
what it does not mean is that they are
pointed towards different objectives so
the omega principle which is one of the
important
principles that undergirds the logic of
the book is that epigenetic phenomena
including culture and all of the
software layer is more flexible than
genes and therefore more rapidly adopt
adapting but it is also
subordinate to the genes in terms of
objective because genes are in a perfect
position to shut down
anything behavioral or cognitive that
does not serve their interests which it
won't do instantaneously but over
generations it will
so what we find is gender has to be
serving the interests of the genes and
therefore sex and gender should be
pointed in the same direction
now there's a lot of variation in the
the gender layer but it is not a
completely independent phenomenon it is
not
superior to the underlying uh genetics
so let me ask you about that in terms of
personality then because i've been
thinking a lot about the sex and gender
issue you know the idea that there's an
infinite number of genders
you know i like to give the devil his
due as much as i possibly can and one of
the things you do see in the personality
literature in psychology which is
reasonably well developed right i mean
we have a pretty good model of human
personality five basic
personality traits maybe they're
subdivisible into two sub traits each so
that's ten it's five dimensions of
variability that's a lot reality only
has four dimensions of variability so
so what you see is that
there are reliable differences between
men and women in aggregate in
personality and and one of the big
differences is that women are about half
a standard deviation more
sensitive to negative emotion and
they're about half a standard deviation
more
uh agreeable so more compassionate and
polite and you can it's not that hard to
point out that well that might be a
logical consequence of sexual dimorphism
so women should be a bit more sensitive
to threat because they're a bit smaller
but also that they have to i don't think
human adult female personality is
adapted to human adult females i think
it's adapted to female infant dyads
and a female infant dot because here's
why you don't see those personality
differences emerge till puberty now
that's also when you get sexual
dimorphism but
boys and girls under 12 11 they're not
different in terms of sensitivity to
negative emotion
but then puberty hits and the
transformation seems permanent
and so it makes sense to me that a
creature that has an infant is going to
be more sensitive to negative emotion
and also what has to be more agreeable
more compassionate because well it's an
infant right and compassion is the right
emotion for
someone under nine months of age it's
just compassion because well they're
born so young right
we we have a very short gestation period
and so they're completely helpless so of
course it's compassion okay so now
having said those differences exist and
there's some other ones but they're more
trivial
there are lots of women who have
male personality
patterns
so you find women who are low in
negative emotion and low in
agreeableness they're quite masculine
that way and there are men
who are quite feminine in their
personality characteristics and and then
you could also say well insofar as
personality is associated with gender
well there is tremendous
ten-dimensional variation and so the
idea that gender is fluid in some sense
and that it's you know not exactly tied
to the underlying sexual structure
there's some
when it's not pushed too far when it's
not political in its intent
there's some validity to the claim so
what do you think about that
biologically yeah i know i think i think
this is exactly right i i would before i
answer that though i would say that no
woman who had ever
brought a child to term would claim that
gestation was short in humans
but i know i do know what you mean i get
your point um but it feels interminable
when you're actually
undergoing it um with regard to sex
versus gender and the sort of you know
gender is is is way more fluid than sex
it is you know sex is binary we have you
know we are a binary sexually
reproducing species with two and only
two types of gametes the intermediate
type of gamete which has a little bit of
cytoplasm and kind of moves around a
little bit you know a little bit eggy a
little bit doesn't work there's
lots of good reasons for this but the
evolution of anti-sogamy the two
different types of gametes is well
understood from both a theoretical
perspective and it's just manifest right
in in plants and animals right
so that is true sex is binary
and then the expression the software to
use um brett's framing or the behavioral
manifestation of
of sex to use as mine of course
behavioral manifestation only works for
animals it doesn't work as well for uh
for plants but you know we see the same
kinds of
sort of i don't know cultural behavioral
manifestation of sex even in plants even
with regard to eggs being more choosy
than pollen
in in plants with regard to who to mate
with so of course there will be a
greater manifestation of ways to engage
the world when you're talking about say
the behavioral manifestation of what
your underlying sex is then there will
be uh for you know what your actual sex
is and you know i i say that as someone
who is gender non-conforming and who was
never confused about whether or not i
was a girl you know this is this is the
conflation these days right the idea
that gender disorder yeah it's yeah it's
real well it's weird how it's flipped
around too because there's a an infinite
number of genders so let's say and well
but if you're kind of acting girly and
you're a boy when you're three well then
your sex is wrong it's like wait a
minute i thought that gender was fluid
and and it's that it isn't binary it's
like how come it's linked to sex so
tightly all of a sudden when you're
talking about
you know
non-stereotypical manifestations of
behavior it's super progressive too
right i mean the idea you know we
growing up in the 70s i was a girl who
didn't like dresses and the idea that
that made me a boy would have been
considered completely anathema to the
second wave feminists among whom i was
growing up right i was just a girl who
liked to get my get my uh get myself
dirty and play in the dirt and go look
for salamanders that didn't make me a
boy of course not right so you know
being interested in things that are
maybe more likely to be things that boys
are interested in is awesome and it is a
hallmark of modernity that we can
embrace such children and same thing for
boys who are interested in things that
have traditionally been more likely to
be things that girls were either
natively interested in or encouraged to
be interested in but it doesn't change
the underlying sex at all when my son
was young three years old at about that
my daughter was about four and a half
and her friends used to get together and
they'd dress him up as a princess or a
fairy and then he'd prance around the
house and he's quite a masculine boy by
the way and this actually bothered me
you know and so i sat down and thought
about it for a long time because well i
didn't know why it bothered me exactly
and then i came to the conclusion that
wait a second you know because i didn't
want him to get confused maybe it was
something like that and some of it was
probably like arbitrary northern alberta
prejudice or who who the hell knows but
what i realized was that if i interfered
with this
in any way that's raised eyebrows or any
of that non-verbal stuff i would be
sending a message to my son that playing
at being a girl is wrong and what that
meant was that i was telling him that
embodying and understanding what it
meant to be female was unethical
and that was a very bad idea and so when
you see that sort of gender crossing
play take place with kids especially at
that age you should you know
take somewhat of a hands-off approach
and understand that they are
one of the ways i know who you are is to
act you out to play you out and to
imitate you and and it's easy to shut
that down and and then you get you get
the kind of divisions between the
genders let's say or the sexes that
aren't that aren't good you can
interfere with that very young but so it
goes to your earlier point about
children effectively exploring
epigenetic space and discovering who
they are and the fact is you can start
with a perfectly random approach to that
right i'm going to try being anything at
all and the point is certain things land
somewhere where there's something useful
to be done and other things don't land
at all and some things are fun for five
minutes and you know heather points out
i think it's a lovely point that you
know we don't rush to get the child who
declares themselves a dinosaur to the
transition clinic right we just maybe
think that'll pass and the fact is we
know enough or at least you know as
douglas murray might say we knew until
five minutes ago
that kids should be allowed to uh try
out
different
gender stuff and usually it just works
itself out
my my granddaughter
ins she watched pocahontas a lot and she
and she had a pocahontas stall and she
insisted for about a year and a half
when she was i think three
that she was poke if you asked her if
she was pocahontas or ellie she she has
two names ellie or scarlett she would
insist that she was pocahontas for a
long time and i thought that was
remarkable you know that she'd caught
something out of that movie that
attracted her so much that she was
trying to embody that spirit and well
that is the point of these sorts of
animated movies is to put put that
spirit forward but it was remarkable how
committed she was i could think about
that over a year at that developmental
stage she's not pocahontas anymore by
the way but i tested it for a long time
and so that play that's really deep
that's a really deep phenomenon
so and it gets to the human imperative
to create story to create meaning
through narrative and you know there is
we've talked about this a little bit
there is not uh
the hero's journey is extraordinary and
universal and in modernity i think it
can just
almost just as easily apply to many
females journeys but there aren't as
many universal stories
for for girls and women and beauty and
the beast is pretty good
i think it's the best disney animated
film and like beauty is really smart
because she doesn't pick gaston he's got
all the markers right right she actually
wants a civ a beast who can be civilized
that's right and he's the the one
advantage that he has gaston is all
persona so he's all the fake bower bird
now he's a big guy and all that but even
that's fake
but and and she's wise because she
doesn't fall for the status markers and
he's completely nonplussed by this
because he's you know he's devoted his
whole life to just developing the status
markers
and so i think it's beauty and the beast
is is there's a hero's journey in that
that's that's very deep and you know
these very some of these fairy tales
some of them have been traced back like
12 to 13 000 years
and so you know if it's that old it's
like a hundred thousand years right
right but this actually goes uh to a
point that you and i have been dancing
around
forever jordan which is
the point about to which level to what
level are these very ancient things
effectively timeless and to what level
are these things in need of change
because we now face an environment for
which they were not built and so the
hero's journey
i would argue just painting with a broad
rush the hero's journey is timeless what
does the hero's journey look like well
it can look like odysseus or it can look
like the fellowship of the ring right
those are very different versions of the
hero's journey and in fact at the moment
one of the things that we need
are stories that are not built by the
market to fill some need but that
actually reflect the transition in what
males and females do in the world that
in some sense one of the positive things
that has flown from
from birth control is that women because
they can now
uh
engage in family planning that works are
free to compete with men in every realm
that isn't physical yeah well one
question we're wrestling with is well
are women just men then
they are not right since the birth
control pill well that's that well but
they are in some way which is just what
you said they're way more like men than
they were before 1950. we are free
because they have control
yes exactly and so part of what we are
trying to sort out in our culture is
well you know to what degree are they
just men or better men even i mean look
what's happening to university
enrollment for example and so we don't
know and that that our that issue of
universality so a student once asked me
in one of my classes at harvard it's
like well if these stories archetypal
why don't we just tell the same story
over and over like exactly the same
story
and i thought that's a really good
question and then i thought well
there's actually an answer to that in
christian symbolism
so
one of the things that's really strange
about christian thinking is well there's
god you know so he's the sum of all good
very abstract though maybe he's a father
but he's way out there and who knows
what to do with him but he's really
abstract well you have to take that
abstraction make concrete you have to
make it embodied right you have to make
it incarnated and so i'm speaking
psychologically about the story not
religiously
so to bridge that gap between the the
ideal image which is archetypal and
universal and the particularity the way
the christian imagination solved that
problem was to say well that ideal was
embodied in a particular time and place
which seems extremely arbitrary but
that's us right because we are arbitrary
embodiments of that
whatever that abstract humanity is and
we have to particularize the universal
to our time and place and that's why we
need new storytellers all the time
right you need new storytellers and you
need effectively a process of selection
it may or may not be affecting the
storytellers but it affects which
stories resonate and so
a perfect example of your
what we do instead of telling the same
story over and over again is we tell a
story
in a
way that is relevant to the current
moment right the allegory of the cave is
the perfect example of this right the
matrix is the allegory of the cave
arguably the truman show is the allegory
of the cave
and the point is there are ways in which
this needs to be you know we probably
needed an updated version of 1984
because we're living it again and
apparently 1984 isn't good enough to get
us to recognize that at a level that
will stop right so
in any case there is a sort of need and
actually maybe this is uh
the way this intersects with the book is
hyper novelty is the uh out of control
process by which the acceleration of
change outstrips the capacity uh to
adapt
that suggests that the pace at which the
stories that we need must be updated is
accelerating and probably too fast for
us to get those stories well you know
it's it's something here's something
that's worth thinking about too in in
that regard okay so
what drives
innovation in computer hardware
it's the attempt to tell stories in to
portray stories realistically because
that's the most technically demanding
and i mean this economically i've talked
to people who've designed these chips
why do we need more and more powerful
chips given that our computers are
already too fast for us it's like well
we keep building these virtual worlds
and we build them because narratives
think about the game market are so
unbelievably compelling and that
provides the economic rationale for
making our machines more and more
intelligent and so we are
hyper motivated to solve that problem in
some real sense now how successful that
is that's a whole different issue but
you know it's just it's worth taking
seriously after all we've all been told
that politics is downstream from culture
so
i certainly like your your point about
it's the uh desire for the realism and
the narratives it's actually driving
technological process although if you
complete that story at the moment it may
be
uh alchemy right it's the mining of
digital gold that is actually driving
the hardware it's in fact yeah well
that's a that's a very strange thing too
yeah so various sorts of ways yeah yeah
it certainly is and god only knows how
revolutionary that is
so i talk to a lot of the bitcoin
thinkers now and and i have a better
sense of what it is and i can't believe
how smart the person was that made it
it's really and the story is just beyond
belief the you know this guy pops up he
makes this thing he disappears no one
even knows who he is for sure it's like
who could make that up right if he's
even a person
well and i'm you know what i'm trying to
do yeah if he's even a person i'm i'm
trying to
update our understanding of stories you
know that's that rather than the stories
themselves i suppose and also to point
out how important they are that hero
archetype i really do think that that's
the story of niche switching
right because see this is why i want to
do a series on exodus and i really like
x-dis and you think about it in terms of
of a story about adaptations to niches
okay so
and all that that adaptation gets
tyrannical it gets cast in stone that's
egypt it's all stone symbolism
it worked once but now it doesn't well
that's that's an adaptation because the
niche keeps changing underneath it okay
so then you have to switch the
adaptation well moses is is the king of
water and it dissolves stone he's the
master of water well what happens when
you lose the adaptation well the tyranny
disappears hooray but then where are you
well you're in this terrible space
between adaptations
you're in a space between adaptations
that's the desert ah
space between adaptations
we call it the adaptive valley and
you're very right that a desert is a
perfect analog for the adaptive valley
it is not a productive place it is some
place one must cross and frankly it has
the same problem as the adaptive valley
on the evolutionary landscape which is
you have to cross it in the right
direction or you're cooked
hmm
so elaborate on that a bit i don't know
the i don't know the valley so uh theory
that we have it's very interesting
yeah we have this very old
metaphor in evolutionary biology
originally penned by a guy named sewell
wright in the 1930s 1932 i think
anyway it describes basically niches and
opportunities as peaks and the obstacles
to moving from one opportunity to the
next as valleys this metaphor doesn't
work as it was initially instantiated
because we didn't really know enough
about genes and epigenetics for it to
work but it can be easily updated and
the basic idea
is
well i would argue it has to be updated
again that to think about a mountain
range with valleys between peaks doesn't
quite get it because if you're really in
a mountain range with peaks you can see
where the other peaks are but that's not
how selection works right you cross into
a valley because your opportunity is no
longer good enough and you guys have to
talk to jonathan pazzo about the symbol
the religious symbolism of mountains
because it's dead relevant to your to
your biological theorizing well it
wouldn't be so because the the
perceptual landscape in some sense is
predicated on the symbolic notion of a
divine mountain so imagine at the center
it's like the fovea of the vision
right everything's clear there it's it's
closest to the center of the of what
would you say mastered territory and so
pyramids are a representation of that
and that's partly why they're sacred and
so
this is act this idea it's not fluke
that that metaphor sprang to mind for
the biologists and it's dead relevant
for a study of religious symbolism right
it could be it could be convergence or
it could be that sewell writes somewhere
lurking in his mind had uh
religious stories that hinted at this
and you know basically preconditioned
him to see that meta for his
particularly resonant well on you i mean
brett has brett actually has been too
modest here you have actually updated
the model in your dissertation
to shifting landscapes of dunes ridges
and plateaus where you know the
selective pressures
can yield you know lines along which you
might be a most adapted form or a you
know an area that can fail you know and
also a volumetric and understanding
where you can fill a space where in
latecomers maybe less adapted not
because they themselves are any
different but because they're late to
the game so you know there's there's a
lot to be experienced there's a whole
lot there's a whole lot to be done but
uh so far
has been mapping out the relationship
between the mountain symbolism in
religious thinking and also the
relationship between that and perceptual
categories and cognitive categories he's
the only person i know that's done that
he did that partly because he spent a
lot of time talking to john varvakey
who's an expert in the cognition of
perception and also interested in
religious ideas but there's a biological
under so okay so then back to the knee
switching idea so imagine these
mountains and valleys and the adapt in
the adaptive landscape in some sense
well you want someone who is at the top
of the mountain but more importantly you
want someone who can travel from one
mountain peak to another and even more
than that you want someone to travel
from a lower mountain peak to a higher
one well
so uh boy there's a whole lot here
one thing is that the skills that allow
you to ascend a mountain tend to be in a
trade-off relationship an important
trade-off relationship with the skills
that allow you to cross these valleys
right and so in some sense those who are
good at starting up businesses aren't
necessarily
the people who should implement them
and of course yeah openness versus
conscientiousness that's that's what
that boils down to basically i i once
heard a very good discussion about
whether or not this is why
uh god kept moses
out of the promised land
exactly yeah because that was going
through the back of my mind he was the
valley crosser right
um so there's a lot there's a lot to be
said for that but the other thing is
that human biblically he wasn't christ
that's why he couldn't get to the
promised land yeah that's the christian
version of that and so and and and it's
related to this it's related very much
to the idea that you just put forward
different skill set in some sense yeah i
mean he wasn't david most fundamentally
but yes yes well
um but let's just say that if all
creatures are caught in this adaptive
landscape issue where you they can't see
the other peaks and crossing happens as
a result of some process human beings
are in a special condition and this is
exactly what we talk about in the second
to last chapter of our book
which is the consciousness the
collective consciousness process
actually allows us
to
effectively
um debate
and discover the probable location of
future peaks without having been there
right yes to know that a peak ought to
lie in that direction
and to move in that direction in some
coherent way this is a uniquely human
capacity it is why niche switching is
our special gift and
you know hopefully it's dependent on the
free exchange of ideas which is no
different than thinking and we do it
collectively yes we do it that's the
thing that not every free of exchange of
ideas works this way it is a
collaborative free exchange of ideas
where people who are agreed that the
what we need to do is get into the
future how best to do that is the
question around the campfire yeah this
collaboration involves ideas being
exchanged which can be altered by the
exchange yes as opposed to as opposed to
read-only uh
receiving i think
so i think that's why see i think that's
why the ancient egyptians worshipped the
eye horus's eye because it's opening
they weren't worshiping intellect
they were worshiping attention
it's different it's really different and
intellect that's milton's
like authoritarian demon attention is
different because when i pay and i
really learned this in therapy the best
way to help someone move forward is to
listen to them
is to listen because then they can talk
and then you respond non-verbally and
that helps them figure out where they're
clear and not clear and then you can ask
them questions like well you said that a
minute ago and then you said that they
seem to be contradictory or maybe i'm
just stupid can you clear up that
contradiction and they unfold
their possibilities unfold as a
consequence of talking but you have to
listen and that's a tension and so and
it's it's the listening that is that
it's such an important part of that
collective transformation of ideas right
do podcasts work this way
well look this is cool man if you think
about this so
i'm stunned at how positive the youtube
comments are
on the dialogues we have like this it's
they're so positive it's just ridiculous
you can't believe it and so they work
like that when they work
right and you know when they work
because you're in the flow state and
that flow state is an indication of
being possessed by that niche switching
capacity
and there's a religious dimension to
that because it's so important to our
survival that it's associated with our
deepest values and we fall into that and
love it people love that and that's
where education takes place too on that
edge that's that edge of transformation
and being there is way better than being
right
yeah it is and playing way better play
requires attention right you aren't
successful and play with someone else if
you're distracted
exactly it's a dance yeah
yeah i i agree with this and it's funny
we hear often about the
terrible fact of what people experienced
on twitter and youtube comments and all
of this we have very often existed in a
state that just didn't mirror people's
description of how terrible these things
were and then sometimes the narrative
shifts on you and so it is almost like a
flow state that you
uh you reach and the audience resonates
and the comments look a certain way and
then something happens sometimes
something intervenes from the outside to
disrupt it and i guess i fear more and
more
that uh
there is so much at stake in the
sense-making that goes on uh in these
forums that something is intervening for
economic reasons or reasons of power
that in other words
uh yeah well that could easily easily
happen yeah i mean hopefully it won't
but because i think it's already
happening yeah well the idea is it's
always it's look we have to fight
against look we have that that's part of
the eternal battle right
that the the
imposition of what's right
against that flow state that's that's
there forever i mean the ancient
egyptians do that they had osiris
they're their gargoto cirrus was a
representation of that totalitarian
proclivity that's the evil uncle in in
the lion king it's this and it is the
the existential psychologists who i like
a lot
one of the things they did was lay out
throne-ness it's right well what do we
always contend with well we always
contend with evil uncle that's the
tyrannical face of history and it's
always
something against which well the hero
battles for example and then often
incarnates in his old age unfortunately
but i mean i'm i'm optimistic about this
and it is play and that's that's and so
people love to be invited that's what's
cool about this too is you invite people
into this you entice them into this you
don't tell them they have to do it
and then they're so happy it's so cool
it's so wonderful to be able to do this
and yeah and then you also think you
just you want to have someone you
actually disagree with to talk to
because you can actually play with them
more deeply if they're being honest
partly because they're way more
unexpected than someone you already
agree with and that also means that flow
state can be deepened because you get
farther right you get more novelty that
gets incorporated and understood
and so that's really
fun too what you just said reminds me
actually of advice that we got from bob
trivers who's uh one of the greatest
living evolutionary biologists and who
was our undergraduate advisor
uh when we were looking to go to grad
school uh he said uh if you end up going
on to being academics to going on to
being professors somewhere you should
find a place where you will be regularly
exposed to undergraduates because it's
by engaging with the minds of people who
do not already think they know something
about your field where you will learn
the most
and um for him although he didn't say it
as part of what he was telling us it was
also part of the sentence of play you
know he was just an extraordinary
lecturer he had a ton of fun up there
and you know we first met him with his
undergraduates and you know watching
watching him play indeed with questions
that came at him from people who were
engaging in good faith but didn't know
what they were supposed to ask was
extraordinary and that of course that's
where we learn the most and where we can
also have the most fun
yeah it's really interesting to hear
that trevor's was like that because i
know of his reputation i mean i know
he's very well regarded by psychologists
as well
particularly for work on self-deception
among among other things so i guess i
knew that you guys were his students but
i it didn't quite sink in that was quite
the privilege eh it was it was very much
a privilege and he was uh a marvelous
lecturer i mean just the man in a piece
of chalk in front of a board was uh was
something else
i should also point out that bob is a
good friend of ours and he was the
officiant at our wedding
so anyway that was an interesting
experience and and one i think we're
both thrilled to have had and answers
interesting actually um you he he's a
man of faith he has he has thank you
talk to me on my my youtube channel very
like yeah hey that'd be great let's do
that so if maybe you could introduce us
because i'd love that i really like talk
to him about self-deception well among
other things he's extraordinary um but
he asked us the day before uh he was to
marry us up in the up in the mountains
of california in the sierra nevada
um some questions just like a clergy
person would you know he really took
this role on very seriously this isn't
something he'd ever done before nor i
since no i think since um but he
specifically wanted to know if we
intended to have children we were in our
late 20s at the point we got married
we'd been together for a long time and
uh we'd never said anything to him about
our intentions or not and
he knew that he would be giving a
different
wedding for us
i don't know if you have children do you
have children oh yeah
well good because you should have and so
hooray well i see i've had i've seen
very many couples that that decided not
to have children and
you know i thought you could have had
some remarkable kids and you would have
been remarkable parents and it's really
too bad that that happened and so i
think the the right way to say it is
that uh
children will destroy your life and
replace it with a better one yeah yeah
right well one of the things i love
about kids is well first of all they're
ridiculously funny and playful
ridiculous they're little clowns that's
so mind-boggling they have sense of
humor like it's like at seven months and
i don't understand that and that's so
funny and they're always playing weird
tricks and and and then the other thing
that's cool and i think this is part of
the theory of mind
issue is that
so
you look at the world through a layer of
latent inhibition right so mostly what
you see is memory you don't actually see
what's there because your brain wants to
take visual shortcuts because it's so
goddamn complicated to look at things
and so you know by the time you're 50
you've seen a million houses so you
don't see any anymore but then you go
for a walk with a two-year-old and
because you can adopt that frame of
reference the world re-novelizes like a
little mini psychedelic trip and that's
something that the infant's children can
you know that's part of the reward they
bring you for having to take care of
them humor play that renovation and then
the other thing i loved about having
kids is you can have the best
relationship you've ever had if you're
careful
yeah
absolutely it's it is it is a unique
relationship because i mean obviously
parenthood is very very ancient and has
nothing to do inherently with human
beings
but the
degree
of
uh what it is to be a human being that
is transmitted after you are born
through
uh interaction and you know not even
explicit analytical interaction but
by modeling
what it is to be a human being and them
extrapolating and then throwing out the
stuff that maybe
is no longer relevant or wasn't that
useful uh as
a mechanism for you and replacing it
with something else it's really an
amazing privilege to be to be part of an
ongoing uh
transmission of adaptive information
down past the generations
spoken like a true evolutionary
biologist i think it's really funny that
you got married by by robert trivers
that's just exactly right that's very
cool so look i think that's a really
good place to stop we've been going for
an hour and 45 minutes and it like
zipped by and and we did stay on your
book pretty good so hooray for us and it
was really fun and i would like to talk
to bob trivers that would be great and
uh i wish you the best with your book
how's the book been doing and tell them
about the book again hold it up again so
because i don't want people to forget
um the book has been doing
spectacularly well in fact so well that
it is now a victim of its own success
it's sold out in three days back on
september
14th and uh
people are getting them but it's uh
they're struggling to keep them in stock
yeah that's a terrible problem that
you've got there it's like oh my god we
were too successful but so you can buy
it on kindle and you get the audio
version and absolutely and you said i
think you said barnes and noble still
has some in stock so that's a good deal
and then you hit you said it hit the
four four number four in the new york
times best seller list yep we sure did
yeah sure did so we're very pleased with
that and just love that people are
reading it and having conversations
about it and you know this this
conversation with you is fabulous and we
are grateful for it and for all of the
conversations that uh we are hearing
that the book is spurring it's really
exactly what we were hoping for great
great well it's really nice to see both
of you you look great uh younger even i
think maybe so that's a good economy we
are we are getting that's the third book
we're going to write about how one gets
younger
if we aren't dead by that right yeah
well all you need is like social
isolation and you know pressure on your
job and and the collapse of your life
and all that and hey you're rejuvenated
so if you're lucky there you go right
yeah like like a phoenix rising from the
ashes
all right well thanks so much jordan
great talking with you too yeah more and
i would say talk to jonathan pagio man
he's deep and you're there's these
there's this linkage of ideas way down
there under the surface that's really
worth investigating he's something so
great you'd have a great
overdue for a talk we've been there yeah
we've been talking about having a talk
for something yeah yeah i think and to
concentrate on this issue of the sacred
mountain that would be unbelievably i
just saw a talk he did to the union
society in montreal that was just bloody
brilliant i'm going to put it on my
youtube channel and so i think that
could be a killer discussion uh the
mountain idea and its role in biology
and yeah that would be something cool
cool all right all right wonderful ciao
guys thank you jordan i hope hopefully
we'll see you again soon wouldn't that
be nice
[Music]
you